hat sich heute morgen in meinen Garten
kam war mein Gewächshaus auf einmal eine
reine Schlammwüste und ich dachte
erstmal ja das müssen die Enten gewesen
sein die haben das ganze Wasser
verplempert habe schön sauber gemacht
und trockene einstreuer reingegeben und
dann habe ich rausgefunden dass nicht
die Enden das Problem sind sondern ich
selbst hier ist eine Regenrinne von
meinem Gewächshaus und hier ist ein
rattengang und wenn es regnet dann
fließt einfach ganz ganz viel Wasser
hier raus und kommt im Gewächshaus
wieder hoch deswegen sage ich hier jetzt
noch drunter dann kann ich das Wasser
auffangen und
sie verschwinden nicht mehr mein
gewechselt endlich wollte ich die Enten
noch mal zum Baden motivieren aber guck
mal wie süß die gerade geschlafen
das ist auf jeden Fall auch ultra
dreckig seitdem die Enten hier drin
wohnen weil die immer alles voll
matschen und vollspritzen müssen da muss
ich auf jeden Fall bei einem Kärcher an